yeah we looked at graphene okay and
Brandie too kind of nice for its own
sake it's like this is cool I hope
you've got a bit of a sensor it's kind
of neat right but the real power of
graphing the real power of thinking
about complex numbers geometrically is
it helps you it yields insight they help
you solve other problems even algebraic
ones that seem like they have nothing to
do with geometry so I'm going to write a
question on the bullet for you we're
going to consider together and then
we're going to see how the geometry can
yield some insight for us okay so here's
the question we're gonna do two like
this that I'm gonna walk you through
okay
this is the whole question now I know we
usually assigned the the meaning of
sixth we usually think of that as order
like in the first second third fourth
fifth all I can see okay but that's not
what this means here but this is our way
of saying if you want to take the root
of a quadratic equation it's a square
root if you take the root of a cubic
equation it's a okay well this is if I
were to write something like this right
this number here this is the principal
sees through I do remember the idea of
principal is and non Prince Awards so if
I said to you hey this guy here right
you get two square roots out of that 25
it has two square roots for which one's
the main one which one's the principal
one positive five yes now when I look at
this this has a value the principal
sixth root we all know the main number
that you multiply by itself six times to
get one is of course one okay so that's
easy to get but there are more there are
other routes and we're going to find
them think back all the way so like our
first lesson we can write an equation
that will help us solve this okay the
equation that goes with this is the
equation that says okay if this is there
are some other numbers that do this
right like a part from one tough me
obvious way you can just say then if
this one thing I can do to this it's
braised both sides to the power six
right so that will give me one on this
side and you'll give me Z to the seats
on that side okay so to solve this I'm
going to write
I'm gonna write this now the heating
i've given you is democracy and complex
rules okay now I want you to call you my
back to how democracy was useful to us
it was when I introduced this we said Oh
polar form right polar forms cool
because if you've got complex numbers in
polar form you can multiply and divide
them super easy do you remember that you
can multiply them by themselves many
many times it for instance I multiplied
this complex number by itself I'd say
six times what would it become for
starters we multiply the modulus right
so that's aa times itself
six times you do that you multiply mods
what do you do with the arguments again
you so you add them six times which
means if you're multiplying by six so
you're going to get this guy remember
that okay so what we're going to do is
I'm going to take this guy and I'm going
to convert it both sides both sides into
polar form I already know what the
left-hand side is going to look like
it's what we just said now what just the
right-hand side look like in polar form
think there's an axe set of axes for you
where is one on the context
the point that complex have a one right
it's on the real other place right and
we measure our ankles our arguments from
the real number plane so if you're on
there if you're on there anywhere on
this positive side your argument 0 or
it's 2 PI over 4 PI I'm gonna says you
don't remember what that was called when
you think that main one it's that if we
use the same way it's the principle
argument okay so this is good
ok I have a look at this you can see on
both sides there's like the the modulus
part and then there's the argument parts
and we just take them one at a time ok
so solving for R you can see just like
when you do quadratic identities you
compare these pieces and these pieces or
if you want to think back to auxilary
angle right you compare your you compare
the amplitude and then you compare the
shift you remember that yes I'm gonna do
the same thing here the ars give me this
do you do that now this is ever so
slightly a different problem to this you
remember I said I'm expecting water
answers out of this in fact I'm going to
expect exactly 6 we get too wild later
on but there are not successes to this
because what kind of numbers are again R
is R is the modulus so that means it's a
distance right the distance that means
it's a positive real number there's only
one number that does that if you're
positive real and that's one I guess
that's good it's unambiguously for all
of the roots that I'm going to find all
of the sixth roots to this they all have
a modulus of one so far so good
and then I've got these two bits right
so now I'm going to solve for theta I
want to find the argument that's going
to give me the right the right roots so
I see this 2 plus or I have to compare
so I've got this bit and this is their
equivalent and then I've got this bit
and this bit their equivalent would you
agree with that
so let's try and tease this out I need
to say that cons six feet up is equal to
close your eye and simultaneously I need
to know that science it's theta is sine
sine zero okay now I want you to
remember we're expecting multiple
solutions here or expecting multiple
solutions we know what the obvious one
is but how do we find the others to help
us what I want you to notice and I'm let
me to draw like a little version of this
movie I want to appeal to your knowledge
of graphing so let's just draw a couple
of these sketches here now if I were to
try and solve this guy right let me just
draw one copy because you know plus six
theta it's gonna go up and down up and
down many many times for infinity I'm
just going to draw one copy of it looks
like this like that that's what one of
the periods of cosine looks like okay
quick question though it's not too
important but for call six theta I mean
usually that's 2pi but usually that's
where we end where would I end if I had
to graph this properly for this rap hmm
well it's it's six times more frequent
do you notice that so therefore from
naught to 2pi I'm going to get six
copies
so therefore this would be two pi
divided by six we should be pulling
through all right now stay with me what
is cos 0
see one right there it is yes cause here
because this is the Costco after all
right in this domain are there any other
places where this graph equals closed
zero
standing down the end right over here
there's a solution okay so these two are
solutions and because this graph goes on
forever and ever ever I can use this as
a pattern to work out where my solutions
would be right okay let's come over to
this guy for a second here's what one
copy of sign looks like what signs
Europe it's zero look see there is is it
any are there any other places within
this domain where that sign curve
intersects resizer
yeah I can teach you there's this one
there and there's one there now have a
look notice please maybe you want to
emphasize underlying whatever it says
aimed right what if peak feed is they've
got to be true he and here he and he
that means I've gotta satisfy both to
have a look at the solutions we got I
found two over here and I found three
over there what am I gonna do with this
guy
if I want to solve both of these
equations at the same time this guy here
I have to say sorry buddy you don't make
the cut
okay because while this right pi is a
solution to this equation
it is not simultaneously a solution for
this equation so I have to disregard its
very good okay
but these guys here Norton 2 pi 1 2 pi
they appear both times so they're good
as solutions for me
ok so therefore I can say I'm solving
for six Peter at the moment right I've
already got two solutions zero that's
you find but I know I've been
emphasizing these graphs they go on
forever right it's just the same graphs
copied and copied and copied so where
would the next solution be 4 pi very
good because again we can take advantage
of the period of these graphs okay where
would the next solution now I could go
on for a very very long time to get it
right I could go on forever there are
infinitely many solutions for reasons
that will become clear in about three
minutes I'm going to put on three more
solutions okay the next one will be 8 pi
the next one would be 10 PI the last one
that I'm gonna write will be 12 pi you
care with that now I'm gonna write dot
dot dot because there are more solutions
and I should also point out if I've got
a dot dot there I should actually also
have a dot dot dot at the beginning
because the graph also goes this way -
do you agree with that so there are
negative solutions okay so if I say good
I've solved for 16 up what I really want
to do is so for feet up so I'm just
going to divide everything by 6
cool all right help me out so why God
well 0 divided by 6 is still 0 2 pi
Pilon three very good full pi/6 bye-bye
okay so you're starting to get a pattern
here aren't you what's this last one
now what I just have a look at the
number what I get is 2 pi right this is
the reason why I went to the seventh one
and I don't think I need to do any more
this guy here
because of what these represent I am
going round and round and around the
complex plane on time right zero hero
zero PI on 3 2 PI over 3 PI 4 PI etc but
once I get back to this right this is
just the same argument as this guy I
don't need to write this again I've
already got it it's the same complex
number right the complex that we can get
out of this you orient that solution
okay so countin I've got one two three
four five six solutions